das ist der etwa hat das ist der baum
den ich letztes mal angezündet habe auch
so von hier komme ich das komplett
ausgebrannt das glas darunter ab dann
darf die möbel der bau bereits
abgelaufen jetzt ist der neun wochen
strom
hey freuen und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge vom mega projekt
zusammen mit mitglied mit krankhafter
wir haben uns gedacht wir die wir
zusammen auf das haben wir letztens
schon mal gesagt bist du traurig wir
zusammen auf das ist ein plan für heute
ist das gros okay jetzt rappelvoll ist
nicht einfach nachts nicht aus dem
raster dach deswegen ist immer so bei
mir also ich mache heute projekt table
also nicht heute einen nächsten paar
folgenden plan project table kraftwerk
generatoren ranch elektrisch
international furniture intels neuer
gang overclocker upgrade solar helmut
leggins recycler maß irgendwas und dann
ja ja genau mein plan ist eigentlich
erstmal mf allerdings habe ich dann
überhaupt keinen bock drauf weil ich
dafür wieder viel zu lange brauchen
werde
das war meine letzte folge ein mfs uhr
gemacht ich würde auch empfehlen direkt
den machen mfg ich war eigentlich in
etwa gleich lange ist ein bisschen
weniger halt noch 600.000 das nicht erst
mal 600.000 eu
du kannst nicht weil sie keine quantum
sachen aufladen nachhaltig html deswegen
macht es dann so ja stimmen sollten 6000
oder zehn millionen ist ja schon mal
weil wir die austrian bis quasi kannst
du ganz ganz viel energie speichern
während der zeit ist und ich glaube ich
ein tattoo der ist wieder so
sich brauchst du eigentlich nur noch die
quasi noch eine maschine bisschen
eisenhaltig sechs diamanten halt habe
ich nicht ich habe eine regulierte
spitzhacke ich wollte jetzt erstmal
farben gehen und zwar redstone verein
deswegen würde also letzte mal bin ich
da hinten willst suchst dir machen hier
findest dann kann ich die mit glück drei
abbauen und gibt etwa eine zwei- bis
dreifache medias also wenn du einmal die
us fans zu genug finden versucht
formiert wenn ich die üblichen helfe
damit ich kann auch einfach dann die
dias an die man kriegt direkt die das
haus nicht abbauen nicht abbauen
höchstens wenn du das heißt es liegt
aber nicht deswegen alte sakristei aber
auch effekte schnell weil das war schon
krass wenn man sympathie diamantenabbau
dann diamant last und blauen vor oder
nach hause nehmen mein glück drei bauen
ist besser als verdoppeln es gibt es ja
fast schon vertreibt vielfach manchmal
der höhe am anfang wo ich zwei mal
gestorben bin ich sehr stolz
wenn jetzt auch gerade relativ hell
draußen es regnet zwar besser trotzdem
relativ l deswegen muss dem bildschirm
auffälligkeit ganz hell haben und
deswegen sehe ich relativ wenig gerade
in höhlen
also ich werde mir dann erstmal
festmachen
sobald ich das hinkriege man kann sich
auch diamanten mit kohle machen auf dem
umständlichen weg na ja genau ich glaube
es ist besser ist seither kohle kann ich
auch für vielfache mit der glück drei
hacke das highschool habe ich auch
ziemlich viel wie du irgendwie handeln
du so willst ich habe dir 46 kohle
das entspreche dann vier diaz auf tobias
ich brauche das definitiv aus texas
schon welche das schon zwei glaube ich
war gestern bei euch allen du darfst
nicht auf meinem grundstück in sonic hab
ich nicht glauben ich weiß nicht ich bin
auch mal kämpfen mal drauf gegangen von
daher habe ich habe ihn auch schon gegen
regeln verstoßen
ich dachte damals stehen betreten
verboten
ja schon wieder draußen ich liebe schöne
andere kannst ruhig angehen solange
alles gut ich kann doch nicht ich habe
auch keine schilder das finde ich nicht
dass eads hundertprozentig der leute
schaut man alle bei denen und guckt ob
der das ist damit würde die recht
weiterhelfen
nimmst eine kiste dann nimmst du drei
ging es ganz oben die obere reihe und
den rest macht aus holz und da sind wir
imstande ist quasi ein crafting meiner
kiste drin wir kannst sachen im tief
drinnen lagern und schon quasi
vorbereiten fest kräften quasi was ich
machen möchte ist einfach solche sachen
die du ein rezept legt dann verbindet
das mittag ist unternimmt der alle items
aus der kiste raus und baut dann davon
so viel wie geht das game geht das
es ist wenn du zum beispiel caritas in
anja genau genau genau der machen durch
pipes machte die ganzen sachen die der
abbaut dann zum beispiel eine kiste band
richter dann verbindet die kiste mit
diesem table der das alles wo du ein
rezept quasi reihen legst und dann nimmt
er sich die ganzen items die er quasi
durch den credit dann irgendwie zusammen
sich fahrt nimmt er dann er dann und
baut das dann quasi beliebig oft nach
und eure tipps einen danke dafür
was machst du ich gleich kurz die tipps
die sie mir geschickt haben den
kommentaren halt so ja da war ich auch
was vorleser was mache ich einfach das
nächste mal wenn ich dann andere
aufnehme ich empfehle einfach so mit
fujitsu kopiert einfach alle rein
kopieren also ein bei sony vegas wo
gibt's denn eigentlich so 10 aufs mal
vorlesen
ja mach ich aber schnell ranch menschen
voll damit kann man geräte abbauen
gemacht
der mensch braucht man dafür
ich brauche jetzt einfach mal ganz weit
weg bis sich auf ähnliche höhen stoße
bei denen nicht jemand war hier meint
auch einige bei diesem baumhöhe du
kannst den abbauen und die blätter der
einschmelzen und dann kriegst du daraus
diamanten für welchen baum bei diesem
komischen blauen der so blau leuchtet
das geht also das meinten leute zu mir
ja bla bla bla ab und schmelz aus einer
kriegs- oder diamanten raus aber ich
glaube ich dass das geht weil da sind
locker in die 100 blätter anderen baum
warum geht das jetzt nicht ich dachte
kann aus titz und das kupfer kann man
große machen wenn man es mit ihm tun
oder vielleicht jetzt erst mal die ganze
kohle mit weile macht mir aus der kohle
diamanten zwar sehr umständlich aber
nicht so ich noch wenn sie ganz kurz
was willst du denn für deine kohle haben
also ich kann dir da nicht so viel geben
ich brauche auch ein bisschen also ich
habe viel habe ich habe 46 und du
brauchst ein ganzes 61 ihm jemanden ich
würde echt nicht empfehlen falls es ist
ziemlich teuer oder sehr teuer wie
industrielle wertvoll wie hast du
brauchst sie für einiges zum craften
also brauchst das zeitweise kohle
wirklich so platten festplatten hatten
ja genau die brauchst du ganz häufig
viele von denen und diverse sachen hat
die krone
egal ob folgen der mensch machen also
bronze points können wir auch eine ranch
geben für 46 ich habe dort einige macht
glaubt jetzt wird nur noch ein mining
machen aber ich weiß nicht ob sich das
lohnt batterien batterien man kann wenn
die enten im rezept drin ist möglichst
auf diese batterie drauf dann kommst du
nicht aufs rezept hin muss die behörde
voll behindert ich weiß nicht warum
ach ja das tun intel eine echte macht
die rheinstädter kannst du 100 prozent
keinen dann verließ die sache nie wenn
du eine normale hast du schon 80 prozent
20 prozent teuerste kaputt getreten und
dann macht die ranch ist geburt rechte
maustaste ist dagegen total abhängig
ich habe eine elektrische damit kannst
du dir nimmst du einfach quasi in die
hand elektrisch aufgeladen ist
dann machst du m und rechtsklick und
dann hast du diesen lost lestrange mode
jetzt kann man alles abbauen ohne also
100 chance nicht kaputt geht quasi gibt
es eigentlich einen strip mining
programm oder irgendwie sowas ja für die
tat ist das was nicht gesehen weil
keiner mehr
nein habe ich nicht das habe uns
zuschauer gemacht ich denke kannst meist
verwenden ich kann danach einen link
schicken ist also einfach du musst
einfach darauf gehen auf die titel
und dann das auf die örtlich sagt
deswegen zum programm hat man sich
herunterladen muss das lesen die zettel
reihen der kontrolle von turtle brauchen
sagt einfügen dann enter und schon und
dann geht sein programm fertig und macht
sich das schon musst du musst nur kohle
haben vater und gestern gemacht
jetzt kann's mir das vielleicht gleich
mal zeigen einfach locker hat der schöne
titel oder machst dir noch einen ehe ich
habe noch niemand etwas muss man geht
einfach meinen platte ja ist ziemlich
billig wenn ich mir vorstelle jetzt
programm auch voll geschockt und ich
dachte man kann in minecraft codes
unterland und programm von die wir von
anderen homepage ist es voll übertrieben
kompliziert irgendwie kann man ja aber
du musst nur contra wochen fertig was da
ohne deine arbeit abgepasst das finde
ich dass man das ist ich finde man nur
so kleine höhle
nach seinen elektrischen tritt auch noch
ribéry
mit kritik wir müssen doch irgendwo
bessere höhlen sein mein gott ich finde
einfach nur gebirge um mein gott was ist
denn das solar den beruf schirm die
schon wieder
das ist der etwa hat das ist der baum
den ich letztes mal angezündet haben so
von hier komme ich das komplett
ausgebrannt das glas darunter ab dann
darf der baum brennt ab dachte ich
weggelaufen
jetzt ist er nur machen strom
elektrischen elektrischen tree cmt
elektronik circuit machte direkt in
massen die kannst du einfach immer
gebrauchen braucht ja davon habe ich
schon übels viele kupferkabel ich weiß
nicht ob ich aus glasfaser kabel
umsteigen sollte ja verhindert deutlich
besser aber ich brauche so viel
diamanten ich hab keine diamanten dass
einen jemand nämlich der glück geld
reich gesagt hat dann lohnt sich das
ich werde meine electric drives alles
richtig gemacht das ist geil voll auf
elektrizität umsteigen es lohnt sich
irgendwie auch geil
er kann ich all deinen enchantment table
verwenden also gerne machen heute hören
nein ich mache mir nach man das davon
aus ja kein nachteil wenn ich den hunger
nicht hassen und aber ich habe halt
einfach zurzeit viel zu wenig zucker
honig jetzt keinen bock drauf 30.000
jahre zu warten dass meine ganze zu
kommen da gewachsen ist kannst du haben
noch ganz viel oben
die rolle des netzwerks 80 kosten
diamanten des parks ist wahrscheinlich
der bühne sind der therapie von alle
bestreiten das mögen wir
das war clever alle auch cool letztes
hat das praktikum geschrieben hey komm
kräfte hat voll was gegen dich der
hastig und er hast deine türme abgebaut
und geklaut und ich glaub ich bitte alle
meine videos an was habe ich gemacht
sich wirst niemals so ein sturm ist also
ich weiß nicht was das für leute sind
die einen dann gegeneinander aufhetzen
wollen das ist irgendwie scheiße auf
menschliche gefühle die wollen nur
unterhaltung zu kämpfen
was bringt die grünen charts ich finde
ich meine wunderschöne titel einen baum
herum
schon darin wir haben alle geschrieben
bzw hat mir gesagt du machst das alles
nur aufzuregen um sich aufzuregen
übertreibt auf das sie sich so böse
gemeint so gesagt ein bisschen zu ärgern
jetzt gleich mal wieder streit haus
machen halter dieser dieser brief maker
dena mahnt fliege schön zurück und
erfahre dass nach das sind meine jetpack
de ländle stromproduzent das irgendwann
mal legt es sich denn jetzt auf das legt
sich aber trotz mainacht auf das finde
ich sehr erstaunlich dass so normal
gehen ich würde beim abnehmen nur mit
jetpack hat man nicht unendlich fliegen
weil auch wenn die energie auf null ist
geht es immer noch ein zweiter also eine
eu und man kann immer weiter fliegen das
habe ich mal getestet bin einfach so die
ganze zeit herum geflogen bin nie es kam
nie zu dem punkt wo ich so kurz darunter
gefallen bin ich konnte ich die ganze
zeit weiter fliegen
natürlich ist es für das was genau sich
auch wie du fliegst oder sogar schneller
genau du kannst nonstop einfach weiter
fliegen gleich noch schneller sogar
gleich schnell einfach sie halt immer
also man ist mit dem jetlag relativ
langsam finde ich eigentlich aber auch
in höhlen in den höhlen ihren höhlen
auch über das heißt die solarien für
sich auf unter der erde oder ich weiß
nicht ob in höhlen aber es gibt eine
übertriebene unlogisch aber nichts
dagegen
also ich finde auf jeden fall sehr geil
diese soll
und da ist auch noch zu wenden da muss
nicht mal boden laufen bei den ganzen
konzert einfach zurückfliegen das voll
geil ich fliege jetzt gerade durch die
wolken
wenn du holzspan hills machte einen
elektrischen twitter kannst ja auch so
eine kettensäge machen bringt nichts
eigentlich habe ich hier recht schon das
rezept für content leggins offen weil
die polizei trat shanes cabras das ist
also kettensäge holz holz aber auch
blätter oder wetter auch weil sie nicht
ich dachte auch ich dachte auch blätter
aber wir nehmen also wie von allen fünf
stück
doch mal ein paar kassen oft in bin ja
so viel interesse habe ich nur sagen ich
werde kurz hin habe ich es mal kurz mit
interessanter wirklich mal ein bisschen
mehr über dem boden
das hat sich erledigt
schade ich dachte werden können oder so
ja also ich kaufe mir ein thema findet
ist wegen kohle oder sowas
also gegen wirklich in gang komme nicht
um einfach euro 5 euro führte
also wie viel kohle wirds geben für wie
viel dann gar nicht selber wie viel sie
ziehen hast du ich war einfach viel sinn
für diese filme lava zellen hat und für
batterien mache ich auch ein bisschen
sind ja ich muss gleich mal gucken
gefüllter nicht habe ich wollte auf
jeden fall die kontingenz machen also
ich weiß nicht ich diese aufnahme mfs
duo oder konnte man sieht auf jeden fall
diamanten und quantum lecken sie kann
zuerst nach dem erwachen quasi